of all how would you overhaul FIFA what
needs to be done here we have to clean
and personally welcome these two
investigation is very important to know
what the configurations official I've
done in CONCACAF and come able and to
know what has happened on the famous
vote or infamous worth of the second of
December 2010 for the two World Cups
2089 22 so I think it's an opportunity
opportunity to clean but also an
opportunity to see clearly the
responsibilities of a various bodies you
have seen and that everyone was saying
that the fifa is responsible but at the
same time you have to know that the
executive committee of FIFA is composed
by the configurations representatives
ufr for example for Europe but these
configurations are not members of FIFA
they're not subsidize the FIFA and if
you follow the text of the US Department
of Justice American the Department of
Justice you can see that it's about
configurations business so this it's an
opportunity to clean it's an opportunity
to also strengthen FIFA and I personally
welcome the fact that we need to give
back the power in FIFA to the National
FS for example the FA over the fact that
in the past 20 years the continental
bodies have gained a lot of leverage
inside the governor of your phone so
that's a very clear blueprint you lie
out I lay out there does that mean
you'll be throwing your hat into the
ring in consideration starts a set
blatta successor I think it's not the
issue so far as you know in a in a
democracy in your country is definitely
the mother of all democracies everyone
is innocent until proven guilty and so
far there was no legal accusation mr.
Blatter is not indicted and far from me
i'm not here to the time but i think
after i would say after the excitation
of the past days i think we need to look
at the facts and not only the headlines
i think it's very important that we look
at the case and as i said it's a good
opportunity to make the necessary
changes and reforms fifa and football
need but mrs. mr. Blatter is to step
down he has already announced that would
you want to be considered as his
successor I was a candidate for a year
and as you remember I was an independent
candidate without
the attack against anyone I produce some
documents on the analysis and detailed
proposal finance proposal on our to
improve he find to improve the game of
football I'm not going to join I would
say the dancing of all the prisoners who
have jumped immediately to try as Andy
Warhol was saying to have 50 minutes of
fame listen I'm observing the situation
and memorizing these things I have not
decided to run again but of course I do
not exclude anything as you say mr.
Blatter himself has not been found
guilty of anything there no accusations
against him directly so has he been
right to say that he's going to resign
in this way once again I mean we the
it's a decision which belongs to him I
don't know I'm like you I'm waiting for
what's going to happen and I don't know
what has happened I think the statement
was clear I was shocked I was all so
sudden but as I said I'm hopeful because
when I was a candidate one of the
central elements of my program was to
give the power to the fs inside the expo
and I'm perfectly personally very
pleased to see that it will be one of
the reforms whether it will be possible
we don't know because in fact the
executive committee has a power but the
decision the final decision is for the
fs so let's wait n see I'm like you I'm
just wedding we're all just waiting of
course and what we're all waiting step
latter as a man who's currently
overseeing some of the reforms well he
says he's overseeing some reforms
already should he have just gone and let
somebody new like yourself perhaps come
in and oversee that process no I don't
think it's so simple last week in fact
the choice was very simple because we
had a man with these qualities and his
defects and in particular is experienced
and on the other side we had someone who
is good person the the president of the
Jordan affair without experience and in
particular without any political
experience that at the top level and we
know now that the sum of the three
candidates have been instrumentalized by
you fr just to develop this camping so
now we to start from scratch again we
will have a new campaign and I do all
that we will have debates with the real
programs not long list of slogans and I
do hope that this process will go smooth
democratically transparently because the
fans need to know will be the person
leading football and fee final years to
come indeed and just brief if you will
sir if it is found that was wrongdoing
when it came to the awarding of two
thousand and twenty twenty two
tournaments should they be reordered
listen principal of innocent until
proven guilty and that is valid also for
the russian vida me Katara bid but as I
said when I was in a candidate I said we
need to know what has happened we need
to know the content of mr. Garcia's
report and as I said if nothing has
taken place will go to these countries
but if the two investigations 1 by the
FBI and the other one by the swiss
federal police discover some things they
will know no problem we'll go for revolt
i think it's clear and but once again we
shouldn't jump on on conclusions and
wait for the outcome of these two
investigation process we all wait to see
Jerome champagne thank you